[Musica]
mio libro storie paurose a scuola di
misteri e ora disponibile in libreria e
online metti alla prova il suo coraggio
leggilo e accumula tutti i punti della
salle nel libro
ha ribadito verità è scappato il
pipistrello da paula a vita o la vita si
può spiegare una cosa è sì
che cosa è successo
sei tornato parti 1 moretti noti speso
fin qui dentro c'era talmente sinistra
ascoltami il pipistrello da morsa inizia
trasformato in un bambino capisce o
trovare il libro per catturare il
pipistrello così tutti potrebbe servirvi
trasforma rivalità dove andate il
pipistrello e si è sbattuto da qualche
parte in camera non lo so devo cercarlo
subito ma no non dobbiamo salvare il
pipistrello dobbiamo prendere libro
catturare il pipistrello e il libro
allontanano dorme e allontanano dal
fisico no ascoltami tu non stai
ragionando in questo momento tu sei un
bambino
aspetta dobbiamo catturarlo il
pipistrello
che mi vorrei border berlino ma ascolta
se invece è semplice pochissimo fuori al
sole
e così in fretta del libro 20 non lo
avrà qui davanti a te perché altrimenti
zincatura io invece convoglio catturare
vogliono catturare pipistrello capisce
che cosa c'è da ridere credi davvero che
quello sia solo un pipistrello
sì l'ho creato davvero volevo comunque
mistrello cercavo di attaccarmi con un
pipistrello e robinho bravo a quello non
è un pipistrello quello e
ola st trova ti
conviene scappare ma che cosa
siamo mio padrone dracula ti ho portato
una vittima da mordere quindi qui anche
allora era già uscito dal baule ovunque
tu sia
dracula ok
[Musica]
chi chi chi è quello
scusi lei chi ha fatto entrare qua
no no no dico
non sapere che devo io e non a
dracula re dei vampiri questo umano è
pronto per essere morso e per essere
trasformato in uno di noi ma prima devo
assicurarmi di una cosa aspetta
ei
no
che paura all'inter che avrei preso il
libro ora non hai più nulla da temere
mio padrone anzi
con animo religioso
ora non potrai catturare trappola
neanche me dentro al libro a storie
paurose e come faccio verso
beh ti dico io una soluzione quale
sarebbe questa soluzione le tue unica
soluzione
per salvarti e
unirsi a noi
dovrei diventare un vampiro come noi
altrimenti altrimenti non hai scampo
quindi che cosa scegliere ma io
veramente avrei un attimo un impegno
importante pranzo di lavoro
vi prometto che tornerò tornerò si si
come no certo che tornerò da voi
aiuto ciao
stupido umano tanto
tornerà tornerà da noi perché la sua
unica soluzione vero
dobbiamo trasformarlo anzi dobbiamo
creare il nostro esercito di vampiri
trasformare più mani possibili e un
vampiri e voi volete diventare un
vampiro come noi
mondo
iniziamo con l'umano e poi piano piano
mordere mutante altre persone finalmente
i vampiri domineranno il mondo non gli
umani ma e va bene
sono molto contenta che ti piace il mio
piano padrone dracula ma ora che cosa
facciamo lo aspettiamo andiamo a
prenderli abbiamo bisogno di cibo se no
ci indeboliremo sam street view è vero
dobbiamo nutrirci di sangue altrimenti
piano piano non riusciremo più a
muoverti dovremmo dormire nelle bare
tutto il giorno quindi aspettiamo che
torni pure l'umano tanto però molto
facile morderlo credo e poi ora noi
abbiamo il libero e lui non potrà
catturarci
ho un piano proverò farle uscire acqua
fuori così con la luce del sole si
indeboliranno venite schiappe
leader virtuale insieme a me essendo la
fuori l'umano
provato a prendermi adesso provate voi
che usciamo da fuori ma troppa luce c'è
troppo tore uffa non sta funzionando
forse devo ballare meglio
credi davvero che cadremo nella sua
misera trappola
non offriamo vai là fuori non sta
funzionando neanche il balletto proverò
a fare l'imitazione di dracula e vediamo
se così si arrabbierà di più e verrà qua
fuori dracula dracula il più grande
vampiro del mondo
che
dracula
[Risate]
stupido umano
questo è un rombo non ti preoccupare
dracula vedrai che tornerà qua e a quel
punto dobbiamo morderlo subito
dici di essere un pipistrello ma quanto
poli sembra una gallina
[Risate]
aiutami marino il piano non ha
funzionato
che cosa possiamo fare tim e parla
chiamare aiuto che posso chiamare
l'ex il lupo aveva detto che in
qualsiasi momento lo potevamo chiamare
in caso di grande aiuto o di urgenza
come gara dovevamo chiamare bussare tre
volte e no però il libro però aspetta
aveva detto che in caso d'urgenza potevo
ululare che urlando lui sarebbe comparso
berlino proviamo dovuto dare insieme
vediamo se arriva
[Musica]
successo è successo è successo che la
vita si è trasformato in vampiro mentina
con con con un altro compito è nostra e
di una puntata google ha contratto
gratuiti praticamente vogliono
trasformarmi vogliono trasformando in un
bambino si no ascolta ho bisogno del tuo
aiuto come posso fare per
fermare questa cosa e far ritornare
anita com'era prima allora allora
partiamo dal fatto che non è un vampiro
comune non è un rampino comune duello è
tra kula il signore dei vampiri del
molto grave questo è gravissimo e
gravissimo e adesso come posso fare
ma quindi ti sei fatto scappare il
pipistrello da paure e come dice nel
baule ma non sapevo ci fosse un
pipistrello dentro quindi quando ho
aperto
è uscito via non sono riuscito a
prenderlo certo certo dovevo
immaginarmelo l'unico modo che abbiamo
adesso se siete a sconto dire è quello
di ricordarci le informazioni sui
bambini nel libro storie paurose
ricordarci ad esempio mi riporto dalla
schiena creatura vampiri che chi viene
morso viene trasformato in vampiro
no non devo essere morto non devo essere
morso sai è arrivato il momento fa
braccio a braccio perché non è vero che
piacerà a quello che ti sto per dire non
piacerà tanto io immediata
e aiuta mi aspetta io ti sto già
aiutando ti do l'informazione chiave è
quella di informazione chiave devi
prendere il libro è solo con il libro e
potrai catturare il signore dei vampiri
e sconfiggendo lui in tutti gli altri
torneranno mai e la vittoria sarà toa mi
sa che ho in mente un'idea su come
convincerli
magari posso dire che voglio unirmi a
loro e così posso ma che farà abbassare
la loro guardia nel frattempo
sgattaiolare a rubare il libro che ne
pensi lei questo è un piano geniale bene
adesso che hai tutte le informazioni che
gli ho dato io posso tornare in
pacchetti montagne
fare le mie cose sai sono molto
impegnato io come il lupo io aiuto tutti
per immagini alex beh il re frattempo
oggi ringrazio vediamo allora alberti di
rex ciao ciao
ciao ragazzi io stavo un attimo
ripensando alla vostra offerta vi
ricordate di unirmi a voi
già funziona
piano piano piano non parliamone un
attimo lo parliamo che prima sono tenuto
del parlando è sicuramente avete ragione
è una delle mie poche speranze chance
chiamiamolo come vogliamo
sì sì sì sì certo che si stava giovani
che pur
un secondo momento per dire
tempo per riflettere e non c'è tempo il
nostro piano deve andare buona
attenzione attenzione invece berlino che
lui verrà trasformato un giorno aspetta
un attimo però mi è venuta un'idea
aleggia già i canini e quindi siamo già
avvantaggiati vedete già già possono
formare un piccolo esercito di quattro
con me e merlino e siamo tagliati con i
canini
basta perdere tempo ma di cosa sta
parlando questo brano trasformano
pronta sì sì sì sì sono venuto qui
apposta per essere trasformato però
aspettate un attimo parliamo in un
secondo è che tutta questa per entrare
aspettando un attimo ci parliamo secondo
io nel frattempo e adesso ho studiato
nel frattempo è ad esempio so benissimo
che ti ai bambini ai vampiri ad esempio
non piace la schifosa
chiarito pesante robot da lasciarti
stecchito
poi nel frattempo ho scoperto anche che
per esempio alle volte avete bisogno di
ordine alle persone perché dal morso
delle persone dal morso delle persone
come dire come dire come dire
[Musica]
logico che non vuole catturare è vero te
lo voglio catturare democratura lui e
catturino e cantore noi anche noi un
giocatore sarà lui quindi spostati
svasati risposta di verità sposta devo
catturare lui da in togliti togliti
subito dritto togliti
no no
[Musica]
nato o no non è partito il raggio dal
libro quindi vuol dire per noi catturò
ho visto non mi schierai questa volta
sono riuscito a prenderlo ma non sei
riuscito a scappare questa volta ti ho
chiuso la finestra a finestra